[Music]
it's that time again Sony have announced
the games coming to Playstation Plus
essential in the month of August 2023.
like always the following games are
available to download from the first
Tuesday of the month which this time
happens to be August the 1st please do
me a favor leave a like even if you
don't like these games pretty pretty
please the headliner of the month is
dreams a game that lets you create other
games from the minds that gave us Little
Big Planet and if you remember that
awesome set of creative tools it had
first released back in 2020 dreams was
designed for players to create the
experiences they wanted to play kinda
like an early version of fortnite
creative if the thought of creating
games doesn't float your boat well don't
disregard dreams right away as some of
the created experiences in dreams are
honestly amazing they are surrounded by
a heap of bad games but there is some
gold here I've Seen the Last of Us
recreated I've seen Crash Bandicoot
wrestling and once I played as the Joker
as he walked down those meme stairs from
a few years ago dreams is weird and
sadly dreams officially halts its life
service in September this year so I
guess this is its last hurray will you
try it okay things don't get much better
now as the next game is PGA Tour 2K 23 a
golf Sim where you take on your favorite
golfers like Tiger Woods here the game
is only nine months old making it
extremely early for it to come to PS
plus a huge thing to note is that the
simulation part of this is really the
drive almost all the rkd elements that
make golf games approachable are missing
here and without a doubt this game is
for the dedicated 25 courses are
digitized for you to compete at and as
you progress a weird RPG system kicks in
which over time increases your stats and
changes the quality of your clubs oh and
there's so much product placement here
it's obscene PGA Tour 2 k23 adds a new
controller scheme consisting of three
timed button presses to try and
reinvigor the genre but if I'm honest
the analog swing is more approachable if
you like golf you definitely need to try
PGA Tour 2k23 if you don't like golf
well tough luck finally an indie game to
save the month this is Death Star a
top-down action adventure title with
engaging puzzles and interesting dungeon
designs here's the setup for Death Star
we are harvesting a soul of a giant
monster only for that soul to go missing
and we find ourselves in this undying
world full of secrets and epic boss
fights to get out of here we must open
death's door with three hard to find
Souls from that point it's up to you to
explore and locate them the blend of
platforming puzzle solving and combat is
honestly quite a joy and from the three
games this month death's door is my
recommendation and it averages scores of
9 out of 10. so go on be honest what
you're thinking what you're playing this
month please share your thoughts in the
comments and please let me know if I'm
being too harsh on these games and I'll
link a video I made a few days ago with
more free games which will tide you over
Tower of fantasy looks particularly good
I'm Adam you're awesome it's been a
pleasure see you next time
[Music]